did you know what a prolapse is
for all the cute little girlies that wanna have like
four or five kids and they just wanna be a stay at home mom
and just love on their babies and raise them
here's a few things you maybe never thought of
first of all
like top one on the list
did you know what a prolapse is
I want you to Google that word
and I want you to understand what a pelvic floor is
and how weak it gets with every child you have
so you know when women like
joke about peeing when they cough
that's a sign of like
your pelvic floor is being weak
and when your pelvic floor is weak
you're at risk of your fucking insides falling out of your vagina and like
you can see them look it up and read stories of
and it is fucking
I didn't learn about it until after I had four kids
all of which were eight pounds or more
one of them was one ounce shy of 9 pounds
I've had some big fucking babies
and I had four of them
that's when I understand I haven't
thank god I'm not there
I haven't gotten to that level and we're
that's why I go to the gym
I anyway anyway
that is a side effect that can happen when you have multiple children
let's talk about more
if you do not take care of yourself when you're pregnant
and give yourself all the nutrients that you need
that's why you're supposed to take a prenatal vitamin and blah blah blah
all the fucking bullshit you're supposed to take and do while you're pregnant
if you don't
the baby comes first
it is almost
quite literally operates like a parasite
it it it sucks at all of the nutrients to the baby
everything goes to the baby
mom kind of gets what's left over
so a lot of times
moms can have teeth issues and hair loss
because everything went to the baby for those nine months
and you just like
didn't realize it
and your body wasn't responding well
you know what I mean
it's like super fun
super fun super fun
also not to mention
you don't really get to decide if you have a vaginal birth or a cesarian
so even if you're like oh
I'm not gonna push the baby out
that's not always your choice
and even if you do decide to get a cesarian
that's major abdominal surgery
they're literally ripping your whole body
your skin your muscle
your or your
fucking your uterine
everything gets cut open for the baby to come out
it's not like
the easy way out
or like a fucking it
I don't know what you think it is
but it's not what you think it is
do you know what I mean
so all you cute little girlies in your 20s
this is just a little public
service announcement from a well seasoned mama of four